Louis every once in a while I make an
announcement that we are again looking
for interns for the david pakman show
and we are coming up again on the fall
college semester and we are accepting
applications for internships this is
typically a good role for either a
college student or a recent graduate of
college ideally interns come into our
studio two days a week and we don't have
interns go and get coffee in this type
of thing in fact I don't think we've
ever had interns run errands for us uh
mmm correct no it's never happened yeah
well Louis seems hesitant maybe you're
doing very very obvious any interns over
the years I'm just thinking way back and
no we never we never did that over the
last few years we have had uh Tegan who
actually learned the entire production
process and was able to do the entire
technical production of the david pakman
show as an intern we had sam who did a
number of great videos including about
vaccinations and about walmart we still
have noah working with us who did
actually the research uh on that viral
reza aztlán takedown we have John
working with us now who is also working
on some incredible Louis compilation
videos for Louis's eventual departure
from the david pakman show so interns
really do actual work that makes it onto
the show if you're at all interested
again it does require you to be here in
the city of boston massachusetts send a
short letter and a resume to david at
david pakman.com